Steve Cortez worked on Donald Trump's
presidential campaign on the Hispanic
Advisory Council and he joins us tonight
thanks up for coming on tonight I
appreciate it so you need sort of thing
you press a little bit on the economic
rationale for this and I no one's
attacking the immigrants I'm certainly
not but you've got to kind of wonder
about the motive if you have someone
arguing simultaneously the technology is
making low-wage jobs disappear and
that's true and at the same time arguing
we need millions more low-wage workers
in this country what is the actual
motive here right no you can't have it
both ways Tucker you and you're exactly
right and by the way I say this as an
Hispanic and as an immigrant son no one
suffers more from illegal immigration
than Hispanic Americans whether they be
native-born or legal immigrants as legal
immigrants go through a difficult long
process to become American citizens so
they are the most cheated when we allow
and tolerate illegal immigration but to
your point two of we know what's the
motive here why does the left want so
many illegal immigrants why do they want
amnesty let's just be honest about it
Tucker
they want their votes they think the
more amnesty they grant the more votes
they will get they're having a hard time
in America they've been in systemic
decline particularly in the state houses
of American elections and they think one
way to reverse that is millions of new
workers millions of new who will flood
the workforce and as you said create an
unnaturally low wage to compete with
American workers many of them Hispanic
they don't care about that but they will
also get millions of new votes so it is
a crass political calculus which they've
engaged in and which they're pursuing
and let's be honest about it so I don't
want to believe that because it's an
inversion of the duty of governments
just to look out for its own people its
own citizens and here you have a state
California where the middle class is
literally running away and enriching all
the neighbors neighboring states and
being replaced by poor people with no
skills who aren't even here legally that
seems like the opposite of what the
government should be doing to its own
people well of course it is
which is why by the way we need listen I
love immigration I'm not anti-immigrant
far from it it's why we need to move to
merit-based immigration chain migration
has been a disaster
for this country it's a disaster for our
economic security for our national
security the visa lottery system is an
insanity that has to be ended yesterday
we need to move to an immigration system
that makes sense for America people who
bring Drive and skills and who love our
country and love our values but that's
where we were historically and where we
need to be again but without chain
migration California would be the
California that voted for Ronald Reagan
twice I mean it said massive political
upside for the Democratic Party no and
again I think that's the crass calculus
that the Democratic Party is engaged in
and you know what to your earlier guess
is right we should take heed here
because often what happens in California
whether it's fashion or television or
politics what happens there does bleed
into the rest of the country and we
should take notice do we want to become
California which right now is in many
ways a third world place it's a place of
incredibly rich elites and there's a
credibly impoverished dependent
underclass that's what the Democratic
Party wants to create through mass
migration through chain migration
through illegal immigration that's not
the America that we want to live in it's
not the America that Hispanic America
was totally right and if you're in Santa
Barbara or Pacific Heights you don't
even see it but it's there Steve thank
you for that that was really interesting
thank you